uh this is Nick Gillespie and this is
the reason live stream with my colleague
Zach weismuller uh and hi Zach thanks
for saying hi
um I am broadcasting from New York City
and that's relevant to today Zach is in
native Florida as is our guest uh
commissioner William Joseph Bratton uh
who was uh who is also calling from
Florida uh at American law enforcement
officer who served two terms as the New
York City Police Commissioner from 1994
to 1996 and again 2014 to 2016. he he
had been the commissioner of the Boston
Police Department and he had also served
as the chief of the LAPD the Los Angeles
Police Department where reason is
headquartered
2002-2009 only person to have run both
the New York Department and the LA
departments uh he is a prominent voice
in the new documentary Gotham the fall
and Rise of New York written and
directed by Matthew Taylor the film
examines the city's safety and quality
of life over several mayoral
administrations between 1966 to John
Lindsay years through 2013 uh the end of
Michael Bloomberg that movie by the way
comes out on March 21st it'll be
available everywhere on video and demand
like apple and all of that kind of stuff
but commissioner thank you for talking
to reason
great to be with you thank you okay yeah
and um you know the I I am talking to
you from one of what used to be one of
the worst streets in New York uh Bleaker
on the corner of Bowery
um
very familiar with it went by and not
because you were going to cbgb's right
you know
um this you presided over the largest
and most sustained uh uh decline in
crime
um you know in a major city in the
United States you know for you know in
recorded history essentially like that
what we want to start with is by playing
a clip that's from the very opening of
Gotham the Fallen rise of New York
because it kind of sets the scene when
you showed up in New York in 1990 uh
Zach can you play this clip
90. the city had an Eastern European
look in the sense that it had an
overwhelming greatness I remember it was
walking in Times Square I knew I wasn't
worried I knew that
seconds somebody would have crossed me
for some reason
bad schools high crime not the greatest
economic vibrancy if you had a car you'd
put a sign in the window that said no
radio in here so that someone wouldn't
come along and smash it up and there
were people begging everywhere
it was terrible
commissioner tell us when you when you
see footage like that's a you know a
kind of medley of what it was like to be
in New York in the late 80s early 90s
how did it feel how did how did people
feel when they were walking down the
streets when they were going into the
Subways when they were you know shopping
or or just you know going to Parks what
was the vibe of the city back then the
Bible the city was its nickname fear
City the police Union had described New
York City back in the late 80s early 90s
as fiosity a very appropriate naming
because it was a place where you were
fearful everywhere in the parks on the
streets in the Subways in particular uh
it was not unique in American cities at
that time but New York being New York it
was the one where all the attention was
focused on and when I first visited
there in 1989 being recruited to take
over as chief of the Transit Police I
described it in my first book tournament
it was awful it was a mess and uh
unfortunately uh some signs of that have
returned once again in 2023
now and it's I guess it's interesting or
important to note too that New York had
been suffering under this kind of a
sense of general criminality for decades
by this point uh starting in the 60s but
certainly the 70s and a good chunk of
the 80s this this was just taken for
granted New York was kind of dead and
you know it might give off heat for a
while but it was kind of lumbering Beast
I was trapped
um you you mentioned you became you were
brought in from Boston to become the
head of the uh the Transit Police that
that watched the Subways in particular
we want to play a clip that kind of
talks about what it was like to go into
the Subways and then I want to get your
uh you know your comments on that Zach
what like taking a walk down into
Dante's Inferno a smell filled with a
lot of the turn styles were disabled
aggressive begging people coming on to
the train everywhere and they actually
had codwood cities on the end of the
platforms
Bratton pioneered this idea that if we
address small crimes in the subway
system we can prevent bigger crimes in
the subway system so they started
looking at who was jumping over the
turnstiles and who was beating the fair
and found out that a disproportionate
number were also wanted for violent
crimes or they were carrying guns or
knives into the subway system so if you
apprehend people beating the fair you
can prevent violent robberies and
murders in the subway system and within
just months of this the times were
saying okay crime is down by double
digits
what uh
uh when you when you see footage like
that I guess before I ask you a policy
question you know
what comes to mind like what what you
know do you break out into a sweat do
you remember things in a particular way
no it just brings back memories of the
bad old days and at the same time it uh
creates the new memories in terms of the
successful churning around of crime in
the Subways that uh and even though the
uh significant problems in the subway
system once again uh it is nowhere near
as bad as it was back in 89 or 90 when I
first took over the then separate New
York City Transit Police it was not
right at the New York City Police
Department at that time yeah the uh the
police uh were uh centralized under uh
it was under your control or did that
come after you were pleased uh actually
I fought aggressively against uh the
chance of police being merged into the
city police uh was successful at doing
that before I went back to Boston but
when I came back in 94 with Giuliani he
had campaigned on the idea of merging
the then three departments together and
we successfully merged them in 1995.
let's talk about in the subway that is
where you know we we hear the beginnings
of things like broken windows policing
Zero Tolerance compstat what were the
policies that you enacted and kind of
enforced in the Subways that really
radically turned around the amount the
volume of crime in the sense you know
that you were going into uh you know one
of the rings of hell
I'm a student of History I love history
and particularly police history and uh
fortunately in my case I made some
history in the 1970s in Boston in that I
adopted a principle of policing that was
first established in 1829 in London the
Metropolitan Police under Sir Robert
peel his nine principles the first
principle was that the basic mission for
which the police exists is to control
crime and disorder in the 60s 70s and
80s most police departments in America
stopped policing disorder and tried to
focus on the growing serious crime
problem you have to focus on both in the
70s and an experimental neighborhood
program I led in Boston we focused on
both and had great success reducing
crime and disorder Kelly and Wilson in
the 80s wrote an article broken windows
and I had been living broken windows
policing in the 70s successfully so it
resonated with me and I became very good
friends uh an acolyte if you will of
Wilson and Kelling in the 80s yeah and
you collaborated on a number of uh
articles and whatnot with George Kelling
in particular uh who ended up working at
the Manhattan Institute but so what did
that mean in in terms of the subway you
go down into the subway
um what changed
1990 three and a half million writers
losing ridership every day close to 200
000 people not paying the Fiat and that
number was growing uh the system when
you entered it a lot of broken turn
Styles in the turn salary uh broken
intentionally by token suckers these are
individuals you'd put your token in and
then they'd suck it out because the
machine would not work or they stand at
the slam grate and hold their hand out
and intimidate you into giving them the
token as you entered we had almost I
believe the number was four to five
thousand people attempting to live in
the Subway's 700 stations we had excuse
me 450 stations we had another 300 that
were actually living in the tunnels uh
many of them homeless many of them
emotionally disturbed meaning the
narcotics addicted we had aggressive
begging everywhere and we had every day
on average 60 or 70 serious felony
crimes including robbery stabbings 22
murders 1990 and uh that was various
serious crime as well as quality of like
crime why the importance of quality
Wi-Fi is what all 350 excuse me three
and a half million buyers saw every day
while 70 of them were victims of a
serious crime each day three and a half
men were victimized by what they were
seeing that was creating fear so what
did you do then to clean up it was you
know the subway it was very easy it's
exactly what the Transit Police now in
2023 doing in New York once again and
surprise surprise the success they're
having is crime is going down and
quality life is improving we focus first
on fear evasion and fear of Asian was a
dollar fifteen theft of service the cops
did not want to enforce if they thought
they were just protecting the red
revenue of the transit authority plus
they would be tied up anywhere from 12
to 24 hours processing that fear of
Asian arrest we structured it so that we
put teams of offices working together
supervise and we would arrest 10 or 15
or 20 Fair Vedas hold them together and
then bring them upstairs and we created
what we call the bust bus it was a
specially equipped bus where we could
process the prisoners right there at the
station seven out of 10 could be
released immediately because they had no
record so we could effectively give them
desk appearance tickets but three out of
ten were found to be wanted on warrants
or in many instances carrying weapons so
the figure we used back in 1990 was one
out of every 21 we arrested had some
type of weapon on them and one out of
every seven had a warrant outstanding
usually for a previous trans defense so
the beauty of what we were doing was the
public saw for the first time in 20
years the police were actively going
after the fair betas two we also had an
advertising budget whether or not I had
money to advertise I I had six thousand
train cars I had a couple thousand buses
we put advertising all over those uh
buses and trains that the police were
back that we were here to take back the
system and we also had an increase in
the number of offices but most
importantly they saw the office is doing
something patrolling the cars making
arrests ejecting the homeless ejecting
the emotionally disturbed injecting the
narcotics addicted and trying to move
them into shelters trying to move them
into services and it was extraordinarily
successful so During the period 1991 the
two years I was there we had double
digit declines in serious crime
extraordinary decreases in Fair evasion
and a sense that the Subways were
getting safer even as the streets seem
to be getting less safe even though on
the streets crime was going down by one
or two percent nobody noticed it why
because on the streets they were
focusing only on serious crime and not
particularly successfully but they were
not doing anything about the 8 000
open-air drug dealing locations in the
city they're nothing doing anything
about the aggressive begging the
graffiti the prostitution the street
prostitution and they're also not doing
much successfully about cleaning up
Times Square so the city above ground
remained a mess even as below ground it
was getting better there's been a fairer
amount of debate which I'm sure you're
aware of in criminology circles about
broken windows policing and what it is
and is not and one thing in your answer
there made me think of one component of
that debate which is
you mentioned Fair uh go cracking down
on Fair Invaders was a big component of
what you were doing in the Subways and
there's one line of argument that is
like well that's really what was the
Difference Maker here is it's almost
like it's it's less about the public
disorder perception of things and more
about you're kind of creating a pretense
or like almost like a fishing expedition
to be able to stop a bunch of people and
then from that you're able to find the
people that have outstanding warrants
and so forth and that is really the part
of it that's that's having an effect
more so than broken windows brought more
broadly understood is there anything to
that what you're describing is the term
is called a pre-text swap that stop that
you're trying to find a reason to make a
stop uh broken windows policing however
is about probable cause it's an offense
a criminal offense or a uh
administrative offense in the case of
the subway oftentimes that the police
officer actually sees the violation its
probable cause he has probable cause to
stop you question you and potentially
arrest you if he finds a weapon on you
for example or if he says he says
there's a warrant for you so a lot of
the uh Hocus Focus that's out there
right now about broken windows is uh
it's inappropriate or the Equator would
stop question Frisk stop question and
frisk is reasonable suspicion the
officer suspects that a crime has been
is or is about to be committed but then
has to articulate why he believes that
is the case in broken windows policing
probable cause the officer Witnesses the
offense and has the legal authority to
do something about it so that's they see
the person jumping the Turn Style and
then
spraying the graffiti they see him
picking the pocket they see him
accosting the the other Riders on the
system so uh the the far left has been
able to really uh muddy the waters
significantly relative to trying to
equate broken windows policing which is
probable cause policing quality of life
leasing with stop question and frisk
both of them of essential tools of
American policing and need to be
practiced legally need to be supervised
closely and need to be defended
vigorously and I'm a staunch Defender
and proponent of both of them
stop question and frisk because that
seems to be the even more controversial
policy where there's been you know real
constitutional questions and you know
rulings against it uh because you're
you're not actually you know as you said
you're not intervening after a crime
it's the co that's the police officer
kind of saying okay this we I believe
that this person is about to commit a
crime and doesn't that contribute
let me explain stop question Frisk is
protected uh and uh governed by Terry
versus Ohio Supreme Court case 1968 uh
we studied extensively when I was in the
police academy 1970 because it was so
new that you have to believe that a
crime has is or is about to be committed
and have to be able to articulate the
reasons for that and that articulation
is critical and what has happened in
recent years unfortunately because of
poor leadership a supervision for
training his offices are not trained
enough as to how to articulate why they
made the Stop and it's allowed in the
case of New York City where it was
overused well intended but overused in
the early 20th century to the extent
that the Legal Eagles on the criminal
defense side were able to make a case in
federal court that what the NYPD was
doing to speak specifically New York was
inappropriate and was unconstitutional
stop questioning Frisk is constitutional
it is a basic element of policing but
you have to safeguard it with all the
required training supervision and
oversight that was not happening in New
York in many other parts of the country
yeah so when when it was stopped in New
York crime continued to go down it
wasn't actually stock let me clarify
that it was diminished significantly by
my predecessor commissioner Kelly it had
gone as high as about 700 000 events
2010-11 when I was appointed
commissioner under de Blasio after
Bloomberg left we got it down to I think
right now they average less than ten
thousand documented stops a year I had
always advocated and one of the reasons
de Blasio appointed me as his
commissioner he campaigned and won the
mayorality in 2013 on the issue of doing
something about stop questioning first
he understood because basically I was
tutoring him that you couldn't do away
with it it was essential but what you
could do was improve its supervision its
implementation and you could do it in a
way that crime would continue to go down
with fewer stops and effectively what
happened in 13 14 15 16 17 18 and 19
crime continued to go down every year
and every year fewer stops and I have
never had a year as a police chief or
Police Commissioner where crime did not
go down during my time as a chief of
police or commissioner never and I
predicted that we would continue
reducing crime but what did we also
reduced we would do summonses we reduce
citations and we reduce the prison
population at leica's by almost 60
percent state prison population went
down by almost 40 percent why because we
were controlling Behavior
misbehavior disorderly conduct and more
serious crime which basically controlled
by effectively put in place compstat the
system that was designed and implemented
during my time as commissioner in 1994.
let's let's talk about comstat uh and
let's start with it in the subway system
because that's that's where it was first
implemented what was comstat and this
oftentimes gets rolled into broken
windows but it's a distinct entity right
can you kind of explain what it was and
how you started I need I need to take
you back briefly to the 1970s when I was
on the neighborhood policing program in
Boston I would go to community meetings
every night something new that the
police going to the community and
talking about crime and I was loaded
with all my crime statistics but people
in the neighborhoods just wanted to talk
about disorder the stuff they saw every
day so my understanding of the
importance of focusing on broken windows
quality of life began in Boston I had
maps in my office covered with acetate
and every night a clerk would put up on
those Maps little dots indicating with
serious climate occurred so we were
dealing with quality of life issues but
also starting to identify patents and
trends that were evolving within a few
days of them occurring so comstat
effectively was created back in the
1970s when I was Police Commissioner in
excuse me a police lieutenant in Boston
I was promoted to the superintendent and
chief physician in 1980 because of My
Success in dealing not only with crime
but with disorder however in the 80s I
left the Boston Police Department we had
several small agencies in Massachusetts
but then in the 1990s going into New
York working with Jack Maple the late
great Jack Maple working together we
began to replicate what we had done in
Boston going after quality of life crime
fear evasion Etc but going after quality
life crime had the residual benefit of
we're also stopping a lot of criminals
but we also began to map and track with
great difficulty on the transit system
because you get 6 000 subway cars moving
all the time the idea of identifying
patents and Trends and who was
committing crime over a very brief
period of time instead of over a long
period of time in 1994 I was beginning
commissioner in the NYPD working with
Maple Louisiana Moon I chief of
Department we created compstat
c-o-m-p-s-t-a-t shot for computer
statistics effectively it was the first
automated mapping of crime that was
occurring in New York City timely
accurate intelligence gather up your
crime reports every day rapidly respond
to what the patents and Trends are
showing you that emergencing effective
tactics what's going to work task Forces
uniform uh what's the best way to deal
with that particular crime and then
Relentless follow-up that even after you
basically made the arrest you kept going
at it to make sure it wasn't coming back
again and what comstat also did it
created transparency because in one room
we would have 200 police leaders from
all over the city come in for three
hours a day twice a week and what do we
talk about crime amazing the NYPD was
going to talk about crime for the first
time in its history in a transparent way
sharing ideas what worked what wasn't
working that's comstep Let's uh we've
got a clip yeah let's uh
documentary about comstat and then I
want to ask you a follow-up question
about how that system actually worked
that program gave us the answer
comstat program gave us the answer
75 percent of the crime is committed in
those days on the platform only 25 in
the cars all the police were in the cars
we took the police out of the car
we put them on a platform where the
crime was taken place
we allocated them exactly the way crime
was allocated 75 percent of the platform
25 in the car
all of a sudden crime went down within
weeks by 50 within months people are
saying the Subway's a safe again
and when the criminals would move back
because we had the comstat system we
were only two days behind them
the city never dealt with crime in a
scientific way like this before in an
intelligent way like this before
so I mean that all it it sounds very
logical the the criticism I want to
raise with you is that there's been
there's two there's two main criticisms
one is that there's been some reports
from these retired officers and other
reporting that perhaps the data uh
comstat can incentivize manipulating the
crime stats by downgrading felonies to
misdemeanors or just not reporting
crimes at all to make the picture look
Rosier than it is and then on the flip
side it can also uh create these kind of
de facto de facto quota system where it
incentivizes police to write a bunch of
tickets for basically harmless things
like blocking pedestrian traffic when
someone's you know standing on a totally
empty sidewalk or something just to
prove that they're doing something in
the comstat like red zone or whatever uh
how do you mitigate those kinds of
problems and the whole like you know
juking the stats type of problem you
mitigate them through the transparency
of the comstat process because in that
process that Precinct Captain is
detective Sarge and they've been there
with dozens if not hundreds of their
peers who are going to very quickly
question uh if something is out of the
ordinary Additionally you also do that
with leadership supervision there's no
denying that there were a few people
that attempted to use shop pencils as we
refer to it but we very very quickly
break those sharp pencils and a number
of people were effectively identified
demoted transferred uh no we do not play
games with the numbers because we
depended on those numbers but was there
that risk that people hoping to
effectively put on a good show certainly
it is occur it certainly did but did it
occur in the widespread way that some of
the individuals you're talking about
tried to present no it was a rarity
rather than even a common occurrence I
might point out also that in the
Manhattan Institute film and the clip
that you just show there's some
confusion the turnaround of crime in the
Subways began in 1990 Rudolph Giuliani
had just lost the 1989 male election and
during the next four years he attempted
to understand to win back the next male
race how to do that and so the
representation in the uh film the video
is that compstat turned Subway crime
around cops that did not comstat as a
system we brought in in 1994 when I was
Police Commissioner but we began the
crime turnaround in 1990 ironically
under mayor David Dinkins in his
administration but I was working for Bob
Kiley the chairman of the MTA I was
working for the president of the transit
authority and while I had to report to
the police commission the mayor I was a
senior vice president of the trans
Authority so the the video in the movie
uh erroneously depicts when did it begin
to turn around Giuliani was able to
accelerate the process significantly on
the streets of New York but the Subways
had already and by that time overall
crime in the Subways was Now by 30 40 50
by the time he was elected mayor yeah I
wanted to uh raise that uh because you
you were hired by David Dinkins uh David
dink or uh yeah Higgins basically was
the mayor right during his mayorality
go ahead I'm sorry yeah uh during his
mayorality um crime crime started
declining in New York in 1990 under
David Dinkins
um uh you know and and as you were
saying it accelerated for sure under
Giuliani and it continued going down
even after crime you know there was a
national declining crime in the 90s at
the exact moment that everybody was
predicting that it was really going to
get even worse and worse
um what do you think accounted for the
turnaround starting in 1990
um you know before Giuliani and the way
the Manhattan Institute movie talks
about it it's it's very much has to do
with people like you but with mayor
Giuliani what was going on between 1990
and 94. I mean 1994 David Dinkins first
black man elected uh in his first year
or two the sis that the city continues
to struggle we had the Crown Heights
riots in the Hasidic area of Brooklyn uh
terrible riots that went on for several
days without being effectively dealt
with so Ray Kelly who was the first
Deputy Commissioner with Lou animone
basically was able to finally bring
those riots under control meanwhile even
as crime was beginning to go down
dramatically in the Subways and be
noticed by the New York Times and others
that because I had a great propaganda
machine I could advertise what we were
doing on the streets people were not
seeing anything different after Dinkins
came in to the extent that the New York
Post had a very famous headline Dave do
something because in his first year or
two crime while it went down one or two
percent it wasn't noticed because the
streets were still a mess eight thousand
open-air drug locations why because the
cops uniform crops weren't authorized to
deal with a lot of that type of energy
and that goes way back right there
it was an anti-corruption initiative put
in back in the 1970s this goes to my
issue about history those who don't know
the history of doing to repeat it I
studied the history of the NYPD very
closely 60s 70s 80s so when I came in
1990 I had very clear ideas about what
to do with the problems in New York and
the corruption issues for one but also
how to get the cops back engaged on the
streets of New York City what dinkas was
able to do and but in some respects
forced to do but as is pointed out in
the uh the Manhattan Institute video
Peter Malone this is a extraordinarily
great talented uh speaker of the city
council was able to work with Dinkins to
get legislation passed in Albany to hire
6 000 more police the department at that
time had I think 25
000 6 000 huge increase and they go to
past amazing Transit Police for example
went from 3 800 to 4100 offices as a
result of that the city police force
increased by almost 5 000 housing
increase but the mistake the tank is
made which is talked about in the video
I think Greg Kelly maybe speaks to this
is that uh he took a lot of the money to
fund social programs first and kind of
put off the hiring of the offices in
large numbers to the end of his term so
that during the male election 93
giuliani's still able to take crime in
the city is a mess and the promised six
thousand officers most of them had not
yet appeared in my first six months as
police commissioner with Giuliani we
effectively increased the size of the
New York City Police Force by 5 000 of
the offices the Dinkins had got the
funding for if Jenkins had front loaded
the hiring of cops instead of the social
work uh programs he probably would have
been re-elected mayor again maybe
because I'm not so sure that the Dinkins
Administration would have focused on
crime in the same way that Giuliani and
I did during our time before we move on
to something a little bit uh different
can just talk about the volume the
number of cops and this is kind of
related to broken windows or or having a
presence how important is it to have a
visible police presence
independent of whether or not these are
good cops or bad cops whether or not
they're you know they're doing stop and
frisk the right way or the wrong way
just having more bodies on the street
does that always have a positive effect
on no it does not let me explain why uh
during Jenkins last year he had more
cops because he was able to hire cops
and I think they increased by about 25
or 50 every Precinct in the city got
more cops but what those young kids were
doing was they were not effectively
going after the things that people
wanted to address the quality of life
crimes Etc so it's important numbers of
as important as what they're doing and
what we did with them at 94 we basically
put the cops back in the street to be
cops to go after the drug dealers to go
after the quality of life to go after
all the crime that was occurring and
I'll give you an example the LAPD I had
9 000 offices in America's second
largest city third largest Police
Department I would have had to have had
000 offices to have had the equivalent
of what I had to work with in New York
City but in Los Angeles during 2002 to
2009 the reduction in crime almost
equaled that of what we did in 1990s in
New York City why because because it's
how we were using the cops we were using
them very effectively very assertively
so it's as much about how you're using
them but in how you're using them is
where the issue of supervision
leadership and training comes in because
if you're not using them appropriately
or if you're not supervising they can go
out of control very quickly and that's
exactly what happened with stop question
and frisk in the period of time
up to 2014 the result in that federal
court case it was found that those
offices these young kids right out of
the academy poorly supervised were
making many inappropriate stops that
they could not articulate
why they made the stop they could not
articulate the Reasonable Suspicion
that's why the federal court came down
so hard on the NYPD in that particular
case could you give me an example just a
concrete example of when what is a good
use of stopping freesque and what is a
bad use of stop and stop question and
frisk
well it basically goes right to the
heart of reasonable suspicion you have
to be able to articulate why are you
making the Stop and in city after City
around the country it's been determined
that many of those stops are being made
inappropriately so it's given stop
question and frisk oftentimes it's
called stop and frisk but the important
part of stop question Frisk is the
question you stop somebody you have the
legal aid to stop them if you have
reasonable sufficient that you can
document but then you question and then
the questioning basically made Lee to
effectively the Frisk the fear that the
individual may be on so it's an
essential tool of policing some cities
of Christ claim that they don't do it
you cannot please any community in
America without the office of having the
ability to do a stock question Frisk
it's like going into a doctor's office
and the doctor's not allowed to ask you
any questions about why you're there
it's uh you know it's it's the
foolishness of trying to do away stock
questions
in New York and will never end in New
York but it's also partly I mean this
gets to to some of the tensions and
certainly in places like New York and La
there were Decades of you know high
tension uh sometimes it detract along
ethnic lines or racial lines but there
have been major scandals uh you know
exactly you know what what had set the
tone for two decades in New York was the
kind of Serpico the book the movie in
the sense that the new NYPD was as big a
grant gang as there was in New York
um that that corrodes trust and
Authority in La uh you know there's
there was a sense uh that the police
acted as almost as an occupying Army how
how do that wasn't a sense that was the
reality in the black communities in L.A
and the reality in New York City the 70s
in particular the corruption issues were
very real uh it was department-wide and
that's where once again the leadership
comes in understanding what's the
history and how do you go about
correcting how do you win back the
Community Trust and in both New York and
in LA a we won back a lot of that
Community Trust particularly the
minority neighborhoods which are always
going to be impacted unfortunately in
our country because of the high rates of
crime that those communities
unfortunately have historically had and
continues to have which draws more
police into those neighborhoods which
ends up in unfortunately more negative
enforcement actions because it was more
crime and more disorder this is where
it's essential to be able to control
your co-ops to the extent that they're
doing everything legitimately if you
will police legitimacy is what the
expression that we use and oftentimes
it's not let properly we've got two
examples of that Memphis and Louisville
Memphis a horrific murder of that young
man by those five cops and now as
recently as yesterday the justice
department coming out showing that
Louisville for most of the last 20 years
was as bad as Los Angeles in terms of
its uh basically being at war with this
black community and it's for me it's
hard to believe in 2023 that that type
of behavior it can go on unchecked for
two decades in the 21st century because
we learned in the 20th century how to
detect it and how to prevent it how are
the ways what are the what are the
concrete things that you do to win back
trust in communities that you know where
the police have kind of [__] the bed as
it were being there uh the old Peter
Sellers movie being there and by being
there I mean in terms of leadership
being there in the community uh in the
70s that uh the reason I got promoted
from Lieutenant to superintendent four
nights a week I was out hosting
Community meetings basically listening
to people that's where I got my full
understanding of Sir Robert Peel's crime
and disorder together you have to do
both and it's the idea of the cops being
there and the cops being there in a
consistent way you hear the expression
community policing neighborhood policing
what is that really effectively it's
returning to the Sir Robert pianwater
the cop on the beat and today it'll be
more likely the cop in the sector car
that uh because we've become so
automated but it is the idea of uh one
uh the increase in minorities and women
on the job so that particularly minority
communities they see people who look
like them uh who are policing them
policing with them uh this stuff is not
rocket science it's a lot of hard work
but we know how to do would I would
argue that did it effectively in New
York did it effectively in Los Angeles
and a lot of the messages of that still
remain in fact during my time with uh de
Blasio
2014 we totally resected the whole city
and set up a neighborhood policing
program modeled after the one we had in
Los Angeles in which every sector has
two neighborhood coordinating offices
who assigned we don't chase 9-1-1 calls
they are assigned to a sector to
interact with the community they have
the go-to people they give the people in
that Community the store owners here's
my cell phone number here's my email
address you have an issue give me a call
and I will try to work with you those
two neighborhood coordinating offices
are then coordinating with the 12 to 16
officers who Patrol that sector
routinely but with police schedules
they've been the city three or four days
a week then they're my days off for
three or four days so you don't have
consistency and that's where the
neighborhood coordinating offices bring
consistency now this stuff is
it's addressable takes a lot of work but
boy it can work wonderfully if you put
the time and effort into it I wanted to
return to something you've said a little
bit earlier about out so a couple of the
components of what worked in New York
was getting the necessary Manpower
putting more officers on the streets and
then being more assertive in terms of
you know looking and intervening and one
of the results of that this is from a
this is this is a chart from a book by
Franklin uh zimmering the city that
became safe and all everything we show
up here is always in the show notes
below if you want to look at our
references but these are misdemeanor
marijuana arrests which you see uh
spiking precipitously in the 90s and
um what's
I wonder what I'm interested to get your
opinion on is now cannabis and you know
we're a Libertarian publication and so
this kind of uh chart is uh you know
alarming to us to say the least and then
um you know in the in the subsequent
years most States at this point have
legalized cannabis on one level or
another I guess my question for you is
how do you think that has gone so far
terribly New York City New York State's
occasion point I had the experience when
I went to LA in 2002 California
supposedly the healthiest state in
America
I basically had a medical marijuana
clinics where you basically get a
doctor's prescription to go get
marijuana and outside every one of those
clinics you'd see quite a few characters
hanging around hoping to scrounge
marijuana off the people going in with
the prescriptions that my prediction for
you I am not a supporter of marijuana in
any way shape or form except for but
there's a medicinal use because I don't
think we so fully understand its impact
on the development of young people or
the day-to-day use that we're now
actually encouraging in my last year
2016 in New York City uh
marijuana was associated with more
murders than cocaine heroin and the
other drugs fentanyl had just begun to
occur during that time what what does
that mean to say Associated that there
was marijuana on the scene crime
associated with uh people trying to rip
off marijuana dealing that it just was
always found at the scenes of so many of
these crimes but you're you're not
saying it was I mean it's not like
during prohibition where you know uh Al
Capone and Bugsy Moran were fighting it
out over booze I mean it's not marijuana
isn't causing it it's just it's a lot of
it a lot of people are using it a lot of
it was in fact with uh criminals
basically going after each other to Rob
each other for the monies that it
generates Rob each other off control of
the sale of it which was because it was
illegal to sell it uh uh it's still
illegal in some instances it might not
part of the issue it is so confusing as
to uh
how do you get it right now there's 1500
illegals locations in New York to buy it
there are three legal locations so the
billions of dollars of tax revenue that
the state claims it's going to get
they're not going to get it meanwhile
that's bad bureaucracy but I mean
bureaucracy isn't that and I mean the
rollout has certainly been botched of
legal marijuana but if uh isn't this a
point in case where it's not marijuana
people don't smoke marijuana and they've
become I've got to kill somebody if
anything they tend to become pretty
chill but by making it legal and putting
it into storefronts like you know nobody
nobody really gets uh you know you don't
see a lot of murders around the uh Black
Market sale of booze anymore like you
did during prohibition wouldn't
legalizing it alleviate much of the
crime that you're talking about if it
had been done properly it was not done
properly in California it's being done
horrifically poorly here in New York
State uh even the idea of restricting
these legal marijuana stores to people
who had been convicted of crimes
involving marijuana so it sets a uh a
bad example in some respects if you will
that because you were involved in the
illegal sale in the past you now go to
the front of the line to try to sell it
legally now the issue here is
just to dilate on that a little bit you
you don't believe in the idea of of of
of a good drug dealer essentially
very clear I am not a supporter of the
legalization of marijuana other than I'm
a strong believer and it's used for
medicinal purposes I think it's use in a
regular way over time we just don't know
there's a lot of studies out there that
are still being studied uh so that this
rush to legalize most of the rush to
legalize by our politicians uh it's
twofold one to prevent uh the potential
creation of criminal records which is a
reasonable uh rationale but the other is
to uh generate money and generating the
money this is where it's going to fall
down because there's not a state that's
legalized that's ever recognized the
money that they thought they were going
to get why because yeah that well I I'm
sure we will I think we'll have to agree
to disagree on some of this certainly we
will definitely disagree on marijuana
yeah and and other drugs and other drugs
and or currently illegal drugs you you
are against you know I I mean because
one of our arguments would be when you
make the sale uh the production and the
sale of these things legal you take the
crime away from it in the same exactly
in the same way that alcohol well
you take some of the crime away because
the illegal Market is still out there
you think the Mexican cartels are
basically gotten out of the business of
uh trying to control the marijuana
they're very busy now with fentanyl
naturally but the idea is there's a way
around that too legalize it but the
black market still generates a
significant amount of the crime in the
sense and also the fact that it's still
a cash business and this the other issue
at the federal level yeah it's still
illegal so you basically have to take
cash because you effectively can't use
the banks so as uh mayor Adams has
complained about in New York City I
haven't seen the specific figures but
the concern about all these illegal
marijuana shops with all this cash on
hand because become targets for
robberies we'll see how that goes over
time well again there's a clear fix to
that but uh Zach
oh the fix is not so clear that's for
sure
so there's been a one one phenomenon in
recent years uh especially post uh the
George Floyd incidents but even
predating that has been the rise of what
has been known as the progressive
prosecutor in several large American
cities
um criminal justice reform-minded DA's
and a couple years ago I talked with
George gascon who was the former police
officer who became D.A in San Francisco
and then La I am curious what your
reaction is to what gascon had to say to
me about the rise of police and the
criminal or sorry the the role of police
and the criminal justice system during
that interview so let me play this clip
from Gaston I just I'd like to get your
reaction big lie versus basically that
we have convinced our community for
years that over incarceration and more
police presence and more prosecutions
actually was leading to Greater safety
one in fact it has probably led to
Greater insecurity de-emphasizing the
criminal process when it comes to
low-level non-violent offenses actually
increases safety in general not just for
those types of crimes but even for more
serious crime what should the
consequences actually be well I
is the term consequences because when
people are saying an attempt because
they don't have money to get housing
criminalizing that behavior I think it's
not only immoral I believe but it
doesn't fix the problem right so I would
say that rather than consequence I like
to use a term you know the right
intervention
so to summarize gascon's argument there
it's that the police are generally the
wrong intervention for a lot of what is
going wrong in public spaces and that
there should be either a more robust
social safety net or some other
organization that intervenes in certain
circumstances I'm sure you've heard this
argument a lot what's your reply to it I
support that argument most of our
complete sheets most cops who have to
deal with all of this the emotionally
disturbed the homeless the uh narcotics
addicted would like to get out of the
business to of something that they're
not trained adequately to deal with that
they're working with laws that are
inappropriate so where gascon is coming
from and for his purposes your audience
people need to understand George Cascon
was my number two in the LAPD most of my
time as chief of police I supported him
when he went to Mesa as chief of police
in Mesa I supported his appointment as
she for police in San Francisco but I do
not support most of his ideas since he
has now gone over to the progressive
district attorney wing of government you
cannot show me one city in America that
has one of these Progressive District
Attorneys were well intended and we
share the belief that Criminal Justice
Reform is necessary we share the belief
that there are a lot of alternatives to
using the police for a lot of these
social ills but until we fund them
adequately till we coordinate and
organize them adequately police are left
as the agency of Last Resort to deal
with them that's the reality and you
cannot find one city in America
Philadelphia
Los Angeles certainly
that has one of these Progressive DA's
that are funded by the George Soros open
Society Foundation that are having
success in reducing crime or disorder
they're all a mess and they're well
intended but the their policies and
procedures are actually not reducing
crime or disorder it's uh it's in fact
the kind of encourage it because we're
tolerating this behavior and seemingly
there's no penalty for misbehavior for
the minor crimes and we're seeing that
in city after City and this is where the
idea of uh broken windows policing comes
in if you see an offense that you take
action that action doesn't have to be
arrest that action excuse me lost that
ear plugged again that action can be a
summons can be a cessation can be an
admonition and uh and that's what we
encourage and effectively that's what's
going on in New York right now in the
New York City subway system they're
making more arrests but they're also
issuing more summonses they are doing
more ejections with the rest being
effectively in some respects the last
resort the universe for people who will
be Peter offenders and relative to Fair
Invasion you'd be hard put to find
anybody that's at Rikers Island now and
a population that's been increased
dramatically that's up there serving
time for fair evasion they just it's it
just doesn't happen you mentioned some
common ground there with gascon on the
issue of
the police don't have to be the people
who handle every single problem
necessarily
um and this is something I noticed in
their Kelling uh your who you wrote a
op-ed with in the Wall Street Journal in
2014 he wrote an essay in Politico in
2015 that we're both kind of making the
same point that a lot of broken windows
has been misinterpreted or misunderstood
uh we've discussed some of that and some
of the conflation that's happened with
stop question Frisk but uh one one point
that our colleague CJ sirmella
highlighted here was that uh in that
essay Kelling said that broken windows
policing is a highly discretionary set
of activities that seeks the least
intrusive means of solving a problem
whether it's prostitution drug dealing
in a park graffiti uh public drunkenness
and moreover depending on the problem
good broken windows leasing seeks
Partners to address it social workers
city code enforcers business Improvement
District staff teachers medical
personnel clergy and others do you agree
with kelling's argument there or you
know clarification about broken windows
that it's there's more to it than the
police need to be out there aggressively
enforcing a reinfection
that's correct he has never basically
indicated nor have I that you have to
enforce with the rest every infraction
but you do have to address the
infraction and that's whether it's the
admonition the move along uh it's also
the idea that uh the common ground
you're talking about that I write about
in my second book collaborate a parish
the idea that uh you want to get people
onto Common Ground isn't that the issue
in America today that we can't get
people into common ground in Congress
and legislators if anything we're
pulling father apart the Common Ground I
think we can uh agree on is that police
not should not be the sole entity
dealing with any of these major issues
that they get jammed up on in terms of
some of these instances of Police use of
force involve the homeless involve the
emotionally disturbed involve the
narcotics addicted and we are not the uh
end-all for that but we are in many
places the only entity that is there to
deal with that problem and that's the
reality the good news of what's going on
these last few years is the recognition
that let's try some different things in
2005 actually working with George kiscon
when he was my number two we created in
La uh Smart Guys and what was the smart
cup it was a trained officer working
with a trained clinician and when we got
a call from a mentally Disturbed person
we would send that car to basically try
to work on de-escalating the issue
rather than just sending two offices on
with all the accoutrements that they
carry with them and you're seeing more
and more of that but the reality is that
police are never going to be able to
take and be taken totally out of the
equation why cost the amount of money it
would cost to have full-time
clinicians to deal with any of these
conditions in our society the money is
just not there so this is where the idea
of community policing comes into play
partnership and this is what Kelly's
talking about in the quote that you just
showed there the idea that broken
windows is never going to work with just
police enforcement it has to work with
what did Kylie and Gunn do in the
transit authority even as we were
arresting Fair evaders uh seven out of
10 of them were stopped but then they
were released with a ticket they were in
jail they were inconvenienced for half
an hour or so but they are
simultaneously cleaning up the subway
they were getting rid of the trash they
were getting rid of the graffiti they
were improving getting rid of the on 6
000 train cars they got rid of that
graffiti that was like the Hallmark of
New York of the 70s and 80s and so it is
with a partnership with the station
masters with the transit authority with
the police there's an exit prime example
the business Improvement districts in
New York that are so successful against
uh Central Park uh buyer Park why are
they so successful they focus on
cleanliness they focus on enforcement
and they focus on furniture the idea of
benches and street lights the creative
idea in Bryant Park of not having
permanent benches but cheers because you
can move around so three or four you
want to sit together you get blue
folding chair and you make your own
little group you want to sit by yourself
take that chair and go sit off in the
corner and it's that creative thinking
that is that what broken windows was all
about with Kelling and Wilson and it's
been part of the misinterpretation of
even the effort to try and Link it
somehow another that it's stopped
question at Frisk as I've tried to
explain to you on several occasions
Reasonable Suspicion probable cause
could I um ask to kind of uh pick up on
a little bit related there I mean you've
talked about bad cops being a problem
um what is where does the protection of
bad cops come from in terms of
um you know is it is it a function of
qualified immunity is it a function of
police Union strength is it a function
of politicians and or police uh
bureaucracy uh leadership not being
willing to actually clean house because
this is also something a lot of
Libertarians a lot of progressives even
some conservatives talk about you know
there's always a theory that well
there's just a couple of bad apples but
it does seem very difficult to actually
discipline police who do really bad
things over and over again it's all of
the four elements that you just
articulated Union issues contracts
arbitration protocols laws in certain
States qualified immunity
the reluctance like of cops and like
many professions doctors Etc to testify
against each other this once again is
where the leadership comes in that
because you can deal with this in every
Department I've worked in I would say to
you that one two three percent of that
department has problematic offices and
in terms of brutal corrupt races one two
three percent what's the LAPD the NYPD
and that's corroborated in a number of
ways in terms of the numbers of
complaints numbers of arrests that were
made against officers so this is where
uh I'm very concerned at the moment with
the difficulty recruiting new Personnel
city after city is starting to lower
standards physical standards academic
standards when I was Commissioner of New
York in 1994 after coming in and dealing
with the dirty 30 corruption Scandal
where I had a whole Precinct that went
uh corrupt on uh my predecessor Ray
Kelly and then uh basically I had to
deal with the prosecutions of it when we
looked at those cops that were wrestling
they had a lot of commonality they were
effectively some of them come onto the
job at age 19 and then worked in the
department for a couple years because
before they became 21 High School or GED
education so one of the things I did in
the NYPD I raised the hiring age to 22
and raised the requirement that they had
to have 60 college credits of the
equivalent why because I'd have the
ability to get a more mature officer I'd
have the ability to look at a track
record on their academic scores and I
would have the ability effectively to
have an officer that that was used to
going to school so as we provided better
training he had already had a background
in terms of that we also found
interestingly enough in New York City by
doing that we would increase minority
hiring why because the City University
of New York System uh basically uh was a
free school and it was heavily heavy
concentrations of minority kids many who
could not get a job who so they
continued their schooling so we
benefited from that because they had not
only 60 college credits they had college
degrees so we were able to effectively
the kids coming in from Long Island with
the kids with high school educations the
black kids from New York oftentimes had
the college education so it was a way of
basically dealing with a multiple number
of problems with a common sense solution
so I'm very worried that everything
we've talked about today requires a
highly trained highly supervised highly
motivated and constantly being trained
police officer and that's something we
do in abysmal job that we don't continue
to train them other than firearms
training a couple times a year and we're
in this strange period where we need
more cops we want more cops but to get
them we're going to start lowering the
standards and what is that going to
result in it's going to result in
Memphis it's going to be so in
Louisville
what role does what role does the the
because this is something we talked
about we had a stream uh following the
the beating of Tyree Nichols and we
talked a lot about these Elites kind of
squads that go into crime hot spots uh
the one in that situation was called the
Scorpion unit and uh the the police
reformer we spoke with in that case
Walter Katz was agreeing with this
notion that creating these elite units
it's kind of playing into that like
you're going into a war zone type
mentality and this particular unit had a
very bad reputation in the neighborhood
um does that play a role in you know
heightening tensions and and creating
the possibility of a really bad
situation as happened with Tyree Nichols
well Chapman shitty after City around
the country that uh the justice
department just announced yesterday
actually got a commission a study to
take a look at these units and I've got
a lot of familiarity with them I've
created enough of them myself to
expanded a number of them first off it's
the idea of the name you got to be very
careful that because so many of the
names basically uh it intended to send
fear interpretation in a sense of
vehicle units Etc uh
but uh Los Angeles had the crash units
it was an acronym that was trying to
still can't tell you what it all meant
but the crash unit gave the impression
of crashing through doors no so uh these
units are essential
essential because we still in America
believe it or not we have serious crime
we still have incredible issues around
violence around narcotics dealing gangs
Etc uh around criminal gangs uh that's
the reality of life in America today
with the gun situation we have so while
we try to do our best to train the
average police officer to deal with
almost everything they have to deal with
that that's the same as you need
detectors for prolonged investigations
you need much the same as the military
has the ranges and the Navy Seals
policing to deal with that criminal
element a relatively small element thank
God in most cities but still they're
there that the average police office is
not going to have the expertise and
capability to take them on city of Los
Angeles this morning had three offices
that we ambushed showing up at the front
doorstep the guy immediately opened fire
on them that you need them but you need
what it seems to be missing certainly in
the Memphis cases I'm looking at it
leadership supervision throughout that
whole scenario in Memphis you never saw
a super advisor you get 20 cops on the
scene from The Circle Elite unit but you
never saw a supervisor so supervision is
critical the recruitment aspect of it
getting the right people in clearly most
of those cops in that unit were not
there the training the tactics were
abysmal abysmal and with were they
trained that way well it's going to be
part of the investigation no these units
like the the Navy SEALS or the ranges or
whatever
they are essential unfortunately in
America today with the violence levels
we have uh there was a way to create
them that they uh uh better supervised
Eric Adams and his new Queen's Mission
just try to do that here in New York
over the last year the previous
commission had disbanded the anti-crime
unit
they have reformed it they went through
an exhaustive process of screening the
candidates changed the uniforms so they
are actually some form of uniform and it
is a heavily supervised unit they've
been a place now just about a year and
knock on wood no significant issues this
year so that's going to be something
we're going to hear a lot more about in
the weeks and months ahead we deserve to
hear about it because the American
public needs to understand why do we
have them and if we're going to have
them how do we control them how um what
do you think explains the increase in
crime I mean you know starting in around
1990 there there was a kind of national
decline in crime you know with with some
hiccups and whatnot started picking up
again during the pandemic essentially in
2020 what's going on that crime is
increasing pretty much first off your
comment about picking up during the
pandemic there's no doubt that the
pandemic was in influence some of that
was the fact that we're letting so many
criminals out of jail early in
unsupervised ways New York City's case
in point but keep in mind New York City
starting in 1990 through 2019 the year
before the epidemic for 29 straight
years crime had gone down in New York
City the jail population at Rikers was
22 000 on average every day in 1994 was
down I think to about seven or eight
thousand actually more Gods than inmates
at Rikers yeah I'm sorry to interrupt
you for a second can you explain how how
does that work because most people and a
lot a lot of critics of you know the uh
police say that the way that crime was
taken down was by throwing more and more
people in jail but basically what you're
saying is crime was declining the number
of people in Rikers was the class I I I
often talk in medical terms I write
about it in my most recent book The
Profession uh you go to a doctor he
examines you you've got a cancer he's
going to give you the option of chemo
radiation in a more serious case surgery
all of those are going to make you ill
for a period of time uh with hopefully
the outcome that he gets the cancer out
and you live the best of your life the
crime situation in America in the 90s
was so bad in New York City I'll speak
to specifically the Subways and the
streets that it was going to require a
population that for 30 years had not
been policed properly and I'm not
talking minority population talking
population in general in the 70s and 80s
New York City the crime went up every
year this is discussed in that Manhattan
Institute video Fred Siegel has a
wonderful book The Future once happened
here looking at in New York Los Angeles
and Washington County that it goes to
broken windows we stopped enforcing
quality of life on the streets it's like
a young child if you don't correct the
behavior as they're growing up they just
engage in more misbehavior so to stop
that cycle it required effectively more
arrests there was no getting around it
there was going to be quiet more arrests
however in 1996 I gave a speech for the
Manhattan Institute which I predicted
and I was very uh uh correct in my
petition it was a bell curve we were
going to make more arrests more
summonses Etc and very specifically
going after the violent criminal but
over time as we control Behavior we
would change it and what happened if you
look at that tracking through the 90s
going forward like his population goes
down from 22 000 state prison population
went down by over 40 percent
and the streets got safer New York City
safest large city America 65 million
tourists but it was the idea that and
even up to 2018-19 that would still
continue I come back in 2014 with fewer
stops stop questioning Frisk few arrests
fewer summonses what was happening jail
population was going down city was
getting safer fewer shootings fewer
robberies Etc and what changed in 2019
the well-intended efforts of the New
York state legislature to correct all
the failings of the previous 30 years
the idea that too many people were going
to jail when in fact the population was
going down dramatically and so uh
a lot of
the
proponents about dealing with crime
argue that covid was responsible for the
surge in crime we're now experiencing
I'm sorry you look at New York City it
began with the political leadership in
Albany you look around the country many
other cities were having success
reducing crime uh up until that period
of time covet influenced it certainly as
many people who should have been kept in
jail for a period of time were let out
as well as the court systems collapsed
in this country they totally collapsed
for two years so you had no system to
identify to hold trials and to
effectively control Behavior if you will
can I uh just follow up real quickly
um uh you you yeah go ahead Zach you
know I just want to explain this this
chart because it bolsters the point that
commissioner Bratton was making there
about the incarceration the the dotted
line on the top is the incarceration
rate in the U.S the bottom is New York
City during the relevant time period and
you see the Divergence there it actually
goes down in New York city so it's not a
year every year yes so it's it's not
like you know just locking up all the
criminals or something made New York
safer and New York during that time
period saw greater cry improvements and
uh reducing crime than the rest of the
nation so
um that that's an interesting aspect uh
to to note of your approach is that did
not require mass incarceration some of
what resulted with that lower crime Etc
was increased tourism increased jobs to
support that tourism the number it had
not been a new hotel opened in New York
uh when Giuliani came out in 94 for
years and then you started having all
these boutique hotels popping up I think
there were like 65 of those basically a
couple years and I remember going with
Giuliani and 94 down to the South Side
Seaport International uh meeting of Real
Estate Investors and telling them Point
Blank you want to start taking a close
look at putting your money into New York
City because we're going to make it safe
and we did and it continues to be a
relatively safe City compared to some of
what's going on in America Chicago
double the number of homicides that New
York has but it's uh right now it's it's
trembling at the moment that uh in terms
of where it was Secure it's trembling at
the moment but I think we'll get through
it uh but it's going to uh one of the
out of crises comes opportunity I use
that expression all the time and so
let's not waste this crises if you will
and find the opportunities that you're
talking about the opportunities for
partnership coordination collaboration
this stuff is not rocket science it's
the I know understand your history what
worked what didn't work and uh what I
worry about unfortunately over the next
two years is we're going into the Silly
Season we're going into the next
presidential election and we're
effectively got two totally Divergent
perspectives very far to the left on one
hand the Democrats very proud of the
white on the white the Republicans uh
you need to get more people to to set
the ground to commonly explain what what
is the problem when you say very far to
the left and that's a problem what what
is the definitive mistake that people on
the left are making and on the left it
is the idea of continued attacks on
police the idea of uh undermining the
legitimacy of police is does policing
have its flaws does the profession have
its issues like every profession it does
but I've been in it for 50 some odd
years and believe me what it was back in
1970 is not what it was in our 19 2023.
uh on the right the issue is this rise
of uh militarism the uh in terms of the
the proud boys and this anger Ed
government I just did a a tweet
yesterday uh putting out uh Chief
managers manga's uh Tom Angel's uh
letter Capital police chief attacking
Fox News for trying to whitewash the
events of January 6th and the idea that
you know how could anybody watch what
was going on on those Capital steps on
that day and say that was uh just
tourists coming to visit but here you
have a national network TV trying to
basically spread that garbage around no
in terms of uh far right far left of
both creating problems and in fact when
I talk about the file UPS I mentioned
also I would go back to George cascone
and the progressive DA's well intended
but whoever the results where were where
were their policies and procedures
they're keeping a lot of people out of
jail great
but we have more murder victims we have
more rape victims we have more people
being high more cities being made less
safe if they were showing success
in terms of reduced crime in victims uh
I'd be I'd be celebrating them I have no
problem with a lot of the reforms they
want to put in place but the way they
join them not working on the far right
the idea of War crops War crops is not
the solution unless those crops are
highly trained you think Memphis is
going to benefit by hiring more cops
like those five that they just hired in
the last couple of years certainly not
um I think the response that the
progressive prosecutors and their
supporters would have is that your uh or
one response have is that your approach
even if it can you can show some uh
empirical results with it the the other
side of the empirical equation there is
that when you kind of flood the Zone
with more police officers and tell them
to go more aggressively intervene
um in the you know problem areas that
the inevitable results of that is that
more people in minority communities more
blacks and Latinos are going to have
more interactions with police more
unwanted interactions with police and I
mean that has been borne out by the the
data you know that they that those
communities disproportionately then get
more uh you know interface with the
police and they're there's inevitably
going to be people who who aren't doing
anything who are walking down the street
getting harassed suddenly I don't deny
that this whole conversation has been
about how to deal with that again I'll
speak to my own time my own record in
the sense of I don't apologize for uh
any of my years in policing in the sense
of 95 96 did we encourage more arrests
yes because that was going to be
necessary to stop the fairways in the
subway to stop the 2000 murders on the
streets the 5 000 people shot in the
streets of New York the half million
people victims of serious crime in New
York I'm very proud that by 2019 before
the state legislation started messing it
up again there were fewer than a hundred
thousand for the first time in history
fewer than a hundred thousand reported
crimes in a city that had now grown from
seven and a half million to eight and a
half million people in a city that has
also become much more minority majority
than it was back in 1994. so it can be
made safer everywhere for everyone I
think I I've got a lot of uh if you will
proof of that I think a lot of the ideas
that I promulgate that I basically with
a lot of the time I spent with Kellen
that I propagate my book uh there are
ways to deal with this to deal with the
issues of race and races Central to all
of this in terms of dealing with the
police I just did an event last night
with Connie rice from uh the Civil Right
advocate in Los Angeles who have got a
great partnership with and was very
helpful with me in Los Angeles trying to
get the race issue in Los Angeles under
control for 50 years the LAPD terrorized
the black community in Los Angeles no
denying it politically as well as uh uh
using the police and we were able to
turn that around turn around fairly
dramatically no this is Hope here uh in
the midst of all of this and shows like
yours are very important because it
allows for the perspective from a lot of
sides to come into view for people to
explain themselves in the sense of I I
do a lot of these why because I'm very
proud of the time I spent in the
profession uh with the mistakes made
certainly and I think overall the
successes and Lessons Learned
can be repeated and expanded upon
I want to ask you about and we need to
be coming to a close yeah absolutely now
and I think we're about 20 minutes over
over that hour now so uh let me uh
finish with this you know over at least
the past 10 years
um you may be a little bit more since
Michael Brown uh was killed in a police
uh you know scuffler by a policeman in
Ferguson Missouri but especially after
George Floyd uh a couple of years ago
there is a narrative now a large story
that is believed by many many people and
it's it's being furthered by black lives
matter in particular but that you know
there there's about a thousand people a
year killed by the police uh it goes up
and down a little bit a subset of that
are blacks uh they are
disproportionately represented for the
percentage of the population but there
is an idea that is gaining ground that
the police the policing of black and
brown people is merely the most obvious
indicator that we live in a white
supremacist Society who's May major
function is to regulate and restrict the
day-to-day life and the possibilities of
black black and brown citizens
um how do you counter that in a way that
does not simply you know turn us to the
next position on the culture War
um I don't count to a lot of that quite
clearly the forces of the far right
the Confederacy rises again effectively
that in terms of the uh the
anti-minority foundation that they're
standing on uh whether it's against Jews
whether it's against blacks that is of
great concern that's I think we're more
divided now than any other time in our
history except just before the Civil War
and so a lot of the issues right now
after the fact that uh Lincoln freed the
slaves in the 1860s but then we had 100
Years of Jim Crow where in many respects
that was probably worse than slavery for
many of the people still living in the
South and uh we tend to forget it's only
what 50 years ago 1960s and 70s that we
really had the Civil Rights Act Martin
Luther King uh you know so we've come a
long way rapidly and that's what the far
right is scared to death of that they're
losing their their Supremacy you talk
about but that's why the police is so
essential to the AC trying to keep them
in the center to deal with the issues of
crime and unfortunately part of the
legacy of what you're talking about is
the rates of violence in the black
community the horrific death tolls that
were experiencing those thousand deaths
that you talk about and the percentage
of blacks that are part of those debts a
lot of that has to do with the fact of
the high violence crime rates in urban
cities in particular that the police are
drawn into and uh you know you'd like
the uh enforcement law to be colorblind
but unfortunately the reality of it it
is not at this time sometime maybe in
our lifetimes it will be but there's a
room for optimism here because there are
things that work it's the idea of really
trying to collectively put them together
and to try to find once again common
ground that Peter Lucas had a wonderful
book Common Ground talking about when I
was a young cop in Boston the 70s one of
the most racially divided cities in
America standing on the schoolhouse
steps being Stoned by the the fathers of
South Boston uh in terms of as a
policeman trying to protect young black
kids desegregating those schools I
didn't think Boston was ever going to
come out of it Boston now has a an Asian
mayor it's a a city that has turned a
dramatic Corner in those last 50 years
so
it was each expression Hope Springs
Eternal I'm an optimist I'm a great
believer in that expression of Hope
strange eternal
what's the opposite that it's uh dismay
and uh I'd prefer to live my life as an
optimist
I think we can leave things there uh but
before we let you go uh commissioner
Bill Bratton um what's your favorite uh
movie depiction of of righteous police
force there's a number of them that uh
I'm a big fan of the uh movie Madigan
Henry fond of Richard Widmark can we
find the commissioner which marker first
grade detective it was based on a book
uh the commissioner that I read in the
50s which was the inspiration for me
wanting to be New York City Police
Commissioner uh what I lived as police
commissioner in 1994 was depicted in
that book from the 1950s and 60s uh
that's one of my favorites because I
think it was a true depiction of the
pressures on a police commission on a
police department there's any number of
them that uh uh there was a movie
crashed to go to the academy award a
couple years ago when I was chief of
police in Los Angeles I thought that was
such an accurate depiction of the city
of Los Angeles as I founded in 2002 in
terms of the racial tensions Etc between
blacks and minorities a wonderful
wonderful movie that was very accurate
in depicting it there's a movie traffic
that I think accurately depicts the
whole issue around narcotics and the the
the Dilemma trying to deal with that
oh no short no shortage of them that
again I I like my uh police history and
so I I tend to like uh we will we will
have you back after drugs are actually
legal and we see that crime disappears
around the drug traffic as well
what you're going to end then see is
that all these movies about zombies
wandering the streets yeah yeah yeah
let's hope they'll be happy and peaceful
uh final final Final question what is
the one thing because you know this is
partly you know there are events that
overtake everybody what is the essential
thing that police forces and beef cops
up to police Chiefs and police
Commissioners can do to win the trust of
of the population which seems pretty
restive right now be true to the oath of
office every police officer takes an
oath of office and basically the hot and
soul of that is to protect and to serve
and to uh uphold the Constitution of the
United States
and uh we saw a lot of that on January
6th that on that day in terms of we
would have lost our democracy on that
day but for the actions of the Capitol
Police and then supported by the
Metropolitan Police I I really do
believe we came that close to losing our
democracy on that day but for the police
I'm very proud of their performance on
that day a lot of problems in policing
but there's in the 800 000 cops in
America there's a lot that every day
basically uphold that oath of office
that they take when they first join
all right well we're going to leave it
there Bill Bratton thanks for talking to
reason Zach wise Miller thank you good
to be with all you all the best okay bye
bye now